[Music]
[Applause]
ah look who's here to join us might be a
swan song is Rick Stroud covers the
Buccaneers for the Tampa Bay Times host
of Sports day Tampa Bay podcast uh
the memories Rick where did they go
where did they okay
um are you are you 100 certain Tom Brady
is 100 retiring
oh you believed him huh are you the guy
yeah call me in 39 days
like last year February 1st February 1st
again
started started free no I I actually do
believe them this time because because I
want to believe him I so badly want to
believe him in the sense that
um we've been through this right and and
I think it you know if you were around
as I was as the people that cover this
team or people who coached this team
last year
it took an enormous toll on him mentally
right like this was not Tom Brady this
was not how Tom Brady prepares
um he had you know had become a single
dad when he was with his children
um you know the team wasn't very good in
the areas it needed to be for him and
and I just think that you know if he was
gonna play again then the best chance
for him was to play back in Tampa I mean
you know it sounds great uh go out to
California or Las Vegas or something
like that just wasn't going to work for
his personal life and it does work here
in Tampa for him from a logistics
standpoint he had done it so uh you know
if you look at where they're at as a
football team 55 million dollars over
the cap a lot of free agents all of that
I just don't think he felt confident
that it would it would go much better
and and I think he's at peace with his
decision how big of a surprise was this
locally in Tampa
I think the timing of it was a surprise
I mean he
um they got eliminated a week earlier so
maybe that had something to do with it
look the guys I people I talked to that
are close to him really thought that it
was likely he would play again
um he absolutely can play I mean the guy
threw for 15 000 yards in the last three
years it's incredible when you think
back I don't think we really give enough
credit to what he did coming in here
during a pandemic leaving New England
the way he did not knowing his teammates
you know getting tossed out of houses
that he thought was Byron left which is
in Parkinson working out with guys and
then winning a Super Bowl the first year
uh was just incredible so they've had an
unbelievable run you know three playoff
appearances two division titles more
success in three years and they'd had
probably in the previous what 25 so
um you know I really think that uh we'll
look back on this as uh as as a good a
good run how did they pull this off how
did Bruce Arians and Brady pull this off
to begin with where they surprised
everybody it was like oh he's not
leaving New England wait he's leaving
new ladies going to Tampa Bay and it
pretty much was almost like LeBron going
to the Miami Heat we we didn't expect it
and then it happened how did they pull
off the surprise
well I think that Tom had some you know
some studying that he had done himself
and and you know I think staying on the
east coast of the United States was
important he has a son in New York
um obviously he was married at that time
he wanted to go someplace warm uh that
was clear and really if you looked at
the football team they were ready to win
a Super Bowl I mean they had a lot of
talent and at that time younger Talent
right three years ago the offensive line
was was had been together for a number
of years and and no matter what the
theories are about Bruce Aryans and why
he did or didn't coach this season and
Brady had something to do with that
um Bruce Harrison said coach Peyton
Manning and Tom likes to be pushed you
know Bruce held him accountable maybe a
little more than he was used to
um but I just think it was a it was a
refreshing change for him you know he
was able to get out from underneath that
belichickian sort of wall uh and find
his voice and have some fun he got Gronk
to come with him you know the brat guys
were together again I mean it was an
unbelievable time and and he really
enjoyed it and somehow they they managed
to put together a really good football
team they were seven and five and went
on a run and won eight in a row so it
wasn't like it was all smooth in the
beginning
um but but what a magical time for uh
for him and for Bucks fans he said
something in his latest retirement uh
video speech where he said he he
wouldn't change anything and it and it
kind of stood out because of what
happened this last year and I wonder if
he needed to go through this to get to
this point that he did he went through
an awful lot off the field uh he went
through an awful lot on the field but
it's almost like he needed something to
say
okay move on with your life now you can
you can walk away from the game do you
buy into that
I I think it's I think there's something
to that I I think we all evolve even at
his age I mean he's as competitive as
hell and the thing about it is that he
can still play and he knows it right but
I think when you go through what he went
through in terms of the divorce and look
people tell me you know second day of
training camp
he gets the word that this is happening
like not and I you know who knows what
goes on in anybody's marriage but like
it wasn't planning on this this wasn't
something that he thought was going to
happen when he went to training camp so
to have to go through a season
um you just he also knew this Dan he can
no longer prepare the way he prepares
right the priorities now become
something different uh when he's by
himself with his children it's not like
hey you're coming home every night you
see him you run upstairs and hit hit the
projector uh projector listen to me it's
it's a you know not that anymore
obviously but
um but I think that his way of preparing
wasn't sustainable anymore I just don't
think he could put into it all that he
requires to do to be Tom Brady now he's
still the most prepared guy if he falls
out of bed and plays because of his 23
years
um but I I think he found it almost
impossible to to prepare the way he
wanted to if Tampa brings in Aaron
Rodgers we'll have you back on but uh
yeah if
if this is it in Sally Field Steel
Magnolias uh you know Norma Ray 80 for
Brady are you
kidding hey I'm honored I'm honored to
be on the show this day it's amazing by
the way how are your Buccaneers moving
forward you mentioned the salary cap
hell uh let's start it quarterback who's
who's quarterbacking the Buccaneers next
year
right now the only guy they have you
know is Kyle Trask so we start there but
listen it depends on who they hire as an
offensive coordinator
um if Todd monkin were to take this job
I'm not sure why he would want it but if
he took this job and came back he was in
Cleveland one year with Baker Mayfield
loves the guy absolutely loves the guy
so there's some free agents out there
they have to bring in but right now
they'll offer Blaine gabbard a chance to
come back on a one-year deal that was
the plan if Tom didn't come back
um and so it's going to be Colin and I
would suspect Blaine and maybe they'll
go after a free agent or something
so you think Baker Mayfield could be or
at least there's the possibility Baker
Mayfield could be the next quarterback
of the Buccaneers
absolutely
um I think a lot of it depends on who
the coordinator is but listen uh they
were looking last year for quarterbacks
when they didn't think when Brady was
out for those 40 days Baker was on that
list
um and you know people say well what
about Jimmy Garoppolo the only thing
about Garoppolo is not a deep ball
thrower now they have Todd Bowles and
they couldn't run it worth a damn last
year so if you're gonna bring in Jimmy
Garoppolo you better find a way to run
the football and that's what they
couldn't do so anything's possible right
now
um but the salary cap is real it's a
problem and uh I think you're limited as
to the kind of quarterback you can pay
um but yeah absolutely I think Banker
would be would be in the in the
crosshairs there well hopefully this
isn't goodbye but until the next time
Rick but uh thank you again you were
always available you always had great
insights and we appreciate it it's not a
funeral but I'm just uh if it feels more
like a wake maybe just uh I understand I
wish I had the 375 million dollar golden
parachute
thank you Rick thanks that's uh Rick
Stroud covers the Buccaneers Tampa Bay
Times and a host of Sports day Tampa Bay
podcast